water is an important resource for
everyone and every living thing access
to clean water for domestic and
agricultural needs can be difficult for
many of us especially if electricity is
not available the intent of this video
is to demonstrate one way to access
clean water using local materials tools
and
skills this is a rope pump it has been
around for centuries but with modern
readily available lowcost materials like
PVC pip pipe and poly rope its use is
making a difference in communities
around the world with this pump water is
pulled up from a 20ft deep handd dug
well at about 8 to 10 gallons per minute
by circulating a rope with Tire Pistons
down the well and back up through the
PVC pipe this lowcost rope pump has been
designed to be constructed operated and
maintained by the local user Community
with no outside
funding for domestic use daily water
needs are n in just a few minutes
through a protected well casing to keep
the water source
clean the pump can be driven by your
arms or legs with one or two
people for expanded agricultural needs
the pump and distribution system can be
easily relocated between several Wells
to maximize
productivity for agricultural uses the
leg Drive is the preferred
method this pump is hooked up to a 3 row
water distribution system made from wood
and painted fabric it is also hooked up
to a locally produced sewn visqueen drip
irrigation system that dramatically
reduces the water
needs here are some detail views of the
construction and components
needed the tools needed are Handa hand
drilling bits knife and wrenches power
tools can be used if
available the hole saw can be locally
made from any steel pipe this one is
made from a bicycle
frame the wood bearings are waxed for
smooth maintenance-free operation in
this wet
environment glass bottles are used to
reduce friction on the Rope at the top
and bottom of the pump
the Pistons are made from the used tire
sidewall the double piston Arrangement
is used to increase efficiency and
extend rope life the locally available
materials you will need are wood one
used car tire rope PVC pipe two glass
bottles wire wax nails and
bolts the 20-ft well was hand dug
encased with the wood used for short
Bing with a pump and water distribution
system like this you can access clean
water for both domestic and agricultural
needs with the pride and security that
comes with building it
yourself one side benefit is
exercise thanks to all who collaborated
to make this
happen for more information on this and
other free assisted technology designs
go to RGA a.net